the problem is it's your [ __ ] life
and it's going to end up one way or the
other
[Music]
possibly
this was last Monday morning they're
like look just so clean I hate the
squeegee [ __ ]
oh yes don't get windy here now that's a
good shot here uh should get it like
yeah I did it
I'll get a few up the branch is [ __ ]
crazy editor okay did it did it myself
the branch is slowed down a little bit
oops these peeps are running pretty good
see you sir color commentary nice
umbrella shift that I did that again
mother [ __ ] yep sorry about that pick
up another one
windy in New York it's windy oh stop how
are you guys doing how's it going I
start introduction great very nice by
the way good morning gonna see well
thanks for having us no problem greater
fear fear fear awesome well thanks
everybody thanks for being here
let me know if I can be helped thanks
Mikey
it's pretty swanky great perfect right
really would like know and feel like I'm
in a snow globe that's what I was I
don't think I'm gonna get my wish you
might get wind a shattered a glass and
you bleed all over okay that sounds
lovely a little sorry I know hi how are
you I'm Gary always how are you
I get it I get it
[Music]
if she says yes what is something you
wanted to be when your kids but never
did a post on IG Thursday and getting me
every set updates and more idea closes
and that's with an occasional control
this hearty on how companies get so like
your dollars on eBay sellers like 30
some 24 that put 30 like use yes it is U
1 3 7 and making adjustments intro oh
yeah today yeah I got orientation today
so I'm kind of doing that get to know
the office and everybody's ready from
one it but what warning the ones and I
move to Houston and yeah
yes I'm going to do my dance in a few
hours and I don't have any help
maybe if you start analyzing like let's
discuss it might be a wet day because
that's why guys collabos oh I know what
else I mean I government I got another
uh always on commercial for incident
story this one I actually think could be
the best got a business question mascara
do search engine like that [ __ ] thing
when people really realize people don't
know people will realize it like it's
real good that's all Y of us jumping in
like with that 3b9 if we all stop and do
our thing interesting made Facebook
algorithm is like the purest form of
capitalism everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 238 of
the askgaryvee show it's windy as hell
in new york i am filming planet of the
apps here in new york city so that's
been fun all day and as we found a quick
15 minute window and I decided to bang
out a Colin show so we're gonna get
right into it uh what are you scared of
art talk to me help me I'm not letting
this is why I'm doing the talent show
because the old show I would have done
your tweet I would have answered it I
would have felt great and then you
wouldn't have done it and I can feel
like I almost got you there but I'm
telling you right now I don't think
you're going to do it and if you didn't
do it didn't do it half-assed will help
me here while you listen I'm on your
team so help me your understand what
you're scared of tell me how many okay
yeah okay so for me like like just
because were like no like no pedigree
and like college education and like
they've set like this sacrifice like
having a fake job so I can do what I
want like I don't want to like
disappoint me nice Nate let me help you
there disappoint for eighteen months and
then make them feel good again burger I
just just tell them tell them listen I
love me for that means you're
appreciative when you love your parents
tell them the truth
start with that I don't want to like
either your parents love you and will
respond to you or they love you that are
so deep into structure and it's been
their whole religion their whole life
that they're incapable even though they
love you too
right through and see it a different way
the problem is it's your [ __ ] life
and it's going to end up one way or the
other
[Music]
Hey next we can win here is if we can do
a little bit more insights digging into
the heaven users or the customers of
this product and segment that from a
psychographic standpoint or from a
demographic standpoint this is exactly
where we can tell our story which is
however you guys creatively interprets
the right one two to three minute videos
we're going to compete against one video
that's 30 seconds that tries to tell a
story I want to walk in with a strategy
that has three videos you know obviously
I want to be empathetic if you have to
come up with six different commercials
for her that lunch on that you know
you're not going to be you're going to
not be able to storyboard and every like
you get as far as you can but minimally
six Manifesto right like German woman
with two kids walks into you know
shopping center and then flash dancing
happens and every baby on earth is cured
I don't feel I don't feel confident that
I can make a 30-second commercial yeah I
mean I mean that's it I don't because I
don't think anybody is like that's the
part I don't think like like that's my
reality like I can't get my like juices
going because I don't know what that
commercial is and like it's so hard I
think more videos are over-indexing on
social media not brand just in general
than any commercials and I think if you
do that behavior you've created your
upside Marcus is one of smartest guys
that work shared sli's in the office
feels very close to my my point of view
he also pushes back extremely well and
just anytime I can add with him to see
if we're crossing our T's and i's
together he's in the trenches he's
always had a good cadence of accepting
forming pushing back informing and so
those you know that said
a minute is what most people spend an
hour and a half on going through a deck
and that's how we do it here I Drive a
fairly big update on can somebody get me
me the details on the snapchat update
how am i doing that was pretty [ __ ]
quick that was Birds you are quick you
click on the Cornell killer menthol is
not a big compliment I don't notice that
when I rather live a very comfortable I
was a quick blue like snapping you like
you're on my land
I'm real strong by the way so I won't
continue crushing YouTube from there I
have this whole other world that's just
like dealing with opportunity right now
now still talking to my main guide I
built out a team so I have an Alex
Matthew just by keeping my World Order
which is incredible quality and license
on up like a million per set and I hit
for 30 under 30
yeah but all these big things along SC
like made me really hire them at social
clout and perceptions like clear up here
right now and I've got like the medium
to follow like I'm nothing compared to
binders and whatever else like I have a
meeting to following and tons of social
perception about right now is on a so
over on brand compared to following yeah
exactly that's what
that direction I want to keep going at
already making funny videos for that guy
myself I'm going to be doing snapchat
you like one every other day your daily
YouTube video I started the society
search analyzer guy that runs and that
it's my music like Xerox and I think
everybody else is using talent as a
North Star and you're making very smart
decision because there's a big
difference about what the wealth on
creating versus what other people are
going to yeah so now let me give you a
really good piece of life tomorrow yeah
get your [ __ ] together on Instagram okay
here's why I just believe it at the most
from attention standpoint yeah I know
that you in four hours can [ __ ]
figure out all the right things to make
it way way way bigger my advisers I love
it Oh
Gary's reason I percent my very first
business which works Thank You Ann
Marie's they continue to crush it so
Gary all my family's guys right here
yeah there are cue gypsy life chasing
their passions like longer business
people sitting in college whatever else
got any advice for them look at me first
of all if you're following this
phenomenal man you've figured out a ton
of stuff but I'll give you a couple of
things I really believe in patience so
many of your youngsters and I have
thousands of youngsters hitting me up
every day like how do I get this how do
I get this patient Shawn you put in so
much work for such a long time now true
and so if you want great things all
great things take time and so one of the
reasons I started dailyvee was to show
people it's [ __ ] work I don't know
where not to car speed like but like
it's work my friends patience and work
and then driving from that passion spot
you can win this game hi great to
officially meet you that was fun thank
Google in that thank you so much no man
are you that's real pleasure sit sit sit
do what you're doing but if you remember
anything from this meeting its
think about three five seven and 10 year
terms for sure and so right so like
build your snapchat because right now is
my second love snapchat said what if
they make a feature tomorrow that's not
bad right like you know build your
where's your facebook at [ __ ] exactly
and it's more important than any of them
it's the only one that's guaranteed to
be around so like you have a blog do you
what's going to have a new email
newsletter like notice
I have noticed Lana notice how weird I
am right like like I'm sitting at the
top right yet I don't any more close to
the biggest numbers on anything right
but it's the collective right that helps
me win and not because not being good
like it's just a collective proper it's
actually having a business it's actually
like like I don't have the most
followers but I also get paid $125,000
to give a speech okay and that's why
being great at everything
what if you go what ifs Instagram [ __ ]
up yeah all the other stuff do not be at
the mercy of a platform you're welcome
awesome yeah
[Music]
I don't want it to be like romance and
I've a lot of everybody by the way it's
100% of my day is based on romance so
I'm never mad when romance hits my face
it's all I [ __ ] get in front of my
face I just want to set that tone of
like and then very honestly you know
with my newfound you know partnership
with Ryan who I think is great at
selling to I'm like [ __ ] this
[Music]
[Music]
like like
[Music]
it is like full belief that every
product will be smart eventually not
just our phones and I believe that even
more importantly as I think about where
AI a our smart application of our
society goes everything that brings
value to consumers is interesting to me
not just the current thing like social
media so I'm always going to bet on
where the attention of the world is
going where the speed can be picked up
and I definitely believe that a smart
products from one of those places so
vaynermedia is one of the early
preferred partners of Amazon's Alexa
skills platform this is a game changer
in a lot of ways a lot of people may not
think this is a big deal but in four or
five years they will you know think in
2009/10 people didn't realize how big of
a deal of being an early partner on the
Facebook platform was and so I'm very
proud of our company and very proud of
Patrick who runs our Vayner smart very
lean team of one to thirteen incredibly
proud of him and super excited for our
brands to get the benefit of Amazon's
skills that I think can absolutely be
disproportionate if there's a first
mover advantage and you win a skill that
people really enjoy and have hundreds of
thousands of people learn how to do
push-ups or eat this specific dish or
learn how to drink wine or whatever it
may be I think there's really enormous
opportunity and I'm I'm excited about
honing my skills deeper in the Alexa
skills world and and voice activation
and things of that nature and I'm really
excited
like that what's up dude
I love you it's fear so fun man I love
those things
oh my god I [ __ ] olesja man I was so
looking forward to this it was the first
conference I ever went to I was so
pumped I come up to him he's in the
corner bunch of people in front of him I
like hey Kevin yeah I do this wiping and
my show once was on the first page of
dig why do you have your badge on right
now because I you just dip in your
called Joey peculiar
long time man he had too long look like
wearing the same clothes and [ __ ] or
just like yeah we just get the little
bug like I do peppermint you got a nice
new fresh haircut yeah all right one
ready sit down
[Music]
[Music]
I
[Music]